number one number one for these children
who once lived in the largest prison in
Lusaka education is a luxury and face my
supa has made it possible for them a few
years ago she founded an organization
called
mother of Millions it looks after women
prisoners and their babies in Zambia's
capital and helps them adjust to the
world outside after their release the
only thing that mother of millions wants
to do is to ensure that the women get
training and they're able to stand by
themselves independent in the community
because sometimes it's hard to
reintegrate into community or society
you know because of the stigma that goes
with it
my mother of millions is supported by
donations the organization is often
short on cash so classes for the
children are usually held in faiths home
faith then drives the mothers to a
training center the ride takes them past
the city's Central Prison which houses
over 1,000 inmates men women even
children when I was pregnant with my son
I decided to pass through the prison on
my left and I was shocked to find
children in prison the conditions of
this children with that setting children
was subject to the same portions of
their as their mother they're sleeping
in cells like their mother
and they were treated as prisoners and
today they are caught circumstantial
children we decided to make a difference
by creating a classroom and impacting
the lives of these children
classes continue after the women are
released from prison mothers learn how
to run small businesses so they can
generate a source of income that's to
ensure that they get an education in
literacy Linnaean and design skills and
by so doing they are able to stand
independently on themselves faith often
has to teach the children the most basic
skills four-year-old Joseph is on his
first excursion after a life in prison
there's much to discover faith is nearby
keeping a watchful eye such an open
place such a place where he can feel
like a child again and that's his rights
I think he's enjoying what is happening
to him I'm happy for him Joseph now
enjoys his freedom but for the many
other children still living in Zambia's
prisons faith Masuka plans to build the
first school behind prison walls in
Zambia